We've shipped a bunch of new features at
DreamFlow. So, let's take a look. First,
we've shipped a whole new properties
panel. Now, the properties panel is one
of the mostused parts of Dreamflow. It's
where you configure, style, and
fine-tune every widget in your app. And
today, we're excited to walk you through
the new properties panel, a groundup
rebuild that makes property editing
faster and more intuitive. The new
properties panel introduces bespoke
editors for tons of property types.
Colors get pickers with theme
integration. Numbers get dragged to
adjust scrub controls. Complex types
like padding, alignment, and shadows get
visual interfaces that show you exactly
what you're changing. It's property
editing that finally feels native to
each data type. So, let's take a look.
Okay, let's open up my properties panel
right here. And I want to go into my
profile here. And I've got this image
that I want to change the fit right
here. And down here I've got this new UI
that recognizes enums. And I want to
change it to cover. Yeah, that looks
better. Next, I want to make this image
a little bit bigger. So here I when I
hover over this property right here, you
can see I've got a couple of new options
right here. I can clear the value, set
it to infinity, or set it to a theme
variable. So when I bring that up, I
have all of my theme variables that are
coming from my theme module right here
that I can bind these to. Or if I want
to make this a little bit bigger, let's
just scrub a little bit. I think like
160 will be about good. Yeah, that's
good. And then I'll just copy this value
over right here. Okay, that's great. But
now that I'm looking at this, I realize
this is slightly overkill and we've got
a perfectly good widget for this, the
avatar widget. So, I'm actually going to
come up to my stack right here. And in
my list of widgets, I'm going to in my
new editor right here, I'm just going to
I want to switch up that clip oval right
here, change the clip oval with an
avatar widget. Now, sometimes this will
make the modification in line or if it's
a larger task, it will delegate it over
to the agent right here. Okay, great.
And there it did it. And it kept the
path, which is cool. Next, I want to
make a change to this guy right here.
So, let me zoom in a little bit and I'm
going to select it right here. And I
want to give it a little border. And
we've got a new color picker right here.
So, you can grab a color right here. See
your recently used ones. We also show
you if you're on a color that closely
matches one from your design system. You
can apply it. Here are all your theme
colors right here. And we provided some
out of the box theming palettes for
material, Certino, and Tailwind. So, I'm
just going to go to my theme right here.
and give it a slight border right there.
And I want it to be um Okay, great. That
looks good. I also want to take a look
at this icon right here because we've
got some new conditional UI that's
helpful. So, if we open up the code
right here, you can see that we've got a
terminary operator that we've got some
nice UI here for. So, we're checking for
the is positive value. And if it's true,
we come in here and we can select this
icon, which is another one of our new
UIs. And if it's false, we use this icon
right here. We also have this UI for
null coalesing operators. If you want to
introduce shadows, you have a new shadow
UI that allows us to add multiple
shadows. So if we come in here, we can
see that we've got a bunch of different
recently used shadows. And so if we
select one right here, you see that we
can stack multiple shadows on top of one
another, which makes for some really
elegant UI. Finally, we have new UI for
common modifiers like padding. So here
we can switch to symmetric or individual
or back to all if we want to add an
alignment. We've got a nice alignment UI
and expansion. Next, we've shipped a
whole new theme module. The new theme
module provides intelligent LLM powered
theme parsing. So this doesn't rely on
hard-coded patterns, but instead uses an
LLM to intelligently understand your
theme structure. This means it works
with standard material themes, custom
theme classes, and any other theme
organization pattern. So once it
understands it, you can visually edit
colors, typography, and style constants.
So let me show you how it works. To
access the new theme module, come over
here and click on this theme editor
right here. You can see all the theme
variables and their types populated.
Now, when you click into each one of
these values, you can see what it's
populated with. You can select the
colors. You can change them. You can see
whether it's dark or light and you can
switch that here or switch that here and
it's synced with your app. So you can
see it in the context of the application
of your design. Now notice here that the
new theming system is type aware. So it
understands what's typography, what's
colors, padding values and much more.
And when you want to apply these values,
let's come in here. Let's wrap this with
padding. You can come into this value
right here and apply the value that you
want. Now, for this project, if you go
in and take a look at our theme, we have
all of our theming in one file. But this
theme module is intelligent. So, in this
project, I've got a different theme
architecture. So, if I look in here,
I've got a theme folder with different
files for colors, dark theme, light
theme, and typography. And when I come
in here, you can see that it's
recognized a structure, and it's able to
pull in all the values. And I'm able to
apply these values in the same way that
I would with any other structure.
Finally, we've made multiple updates to
our agent. Dreamflow now supports
agents.md rules. Agents.mmd has become
the industry standard model for
directing agents. It was created by a
collaboration between openai codecs,
AMP, jewels from Google, cursor, and
factory and is now overseen by the AI
agentic foundation. Agents.md is like a
readme for your agents. a dedicated,
predictable place to provide the context
and instructions to help AI coding
agents work on your project. It defines
your codebases patterns, conventions,
and architectural decisions in one
place, and the agent will follow them
when generating and modifying code.
Here's how you set it up. In order to
get started with agents.md, you can just
come down here to rules, and when I
select it here, I can autogenerate this
file. It'll ask the agent to generate
this and the agent will scan your
project to understand the codebase so
that it can intelligently compose this
file. Great. It's created this file. So,
let's open it up. We've got a project
overview, architectural patterns, and
let's see here. File structure, code
style. Yeah, this is great. This will
help your agent be much more consistent
and higher quality in its generations.
Also, we've added Gemini 3.0 Flash, a
super fast, costefficient, and high
quality coding model. Remember that all
the models are down here in this menu,
so you can just open it up and select
it. Those are the updates for this
December. Leave us any questions you
have below and we'll see you in the next